[Music]
um
we've done a lot of skyping and zooming
in the last year
it's led to more than a few technical
issues to say the least for example this
happened last summer when i was talking
with bones and c seal team actor david
borianis
i wish i i can't hear you but i wish i
could read lips but i can't i'll put
louie down
okay um navy seal
navy navy no okay
this is like a game sounds like a shirt
okay
you play playing yes seal team
yes yes seal team
i did look half the interview
now in honor of maya lending her voice
to the animated film luca
we're going to take away her voice for
another round of the david boreanaz
can't hear me game
get it jesse uh do you like a good game
night maya
i love it bring it on kelly i do too
hey well we're not competing this time
we're together but man next time we will
go against each other because i sense
the competitive energy and i'm really
into no no no
i i'm also i always lose so
oh you know what apparently on this show
i do as well
like i don't know what that's happening
a good game night at someone's house i
am the hero but not here um well this is
a virtual version of the
the classic 19th century game charades
uh maya and i will take turns trying to
get the other
to say a word or phrase the catch is we
will be on mute so we can't hear each
other
um since we're on mute we're allowed to
say the words use
motions and use props if we want to pass
we hold up our pass card
if we can get a total of six words
correct in two rounds
everyone in our house seats will win a
prize so let's not fail them maya
all right let's do it mute my mic and
i'll go first
okay let's get uh 60 seconds on the
clock are we ready i'm so ready okay
and go okay okay oh are we
starting oh you're a dog you're a dog
you're a puppy you're a pet two words
second word second word bark
second word dog hot
hot dog
hair brown blonde
blonde blonde hair she said it blonde
she said it
dumb blonde blonde oh oh um hey
who are you i'm yelling at you why am i
yelling i can't do this
because i took my shoe off pass okay
um i'm sitting down where's my shoe oh
no i fell down
i fell down oh no i'm rolling rolling
stones
break break
break oh rock and roll rock and roll
rock and roll
break oh kelly clarkson hey america
what's happening um
[Applause]
dancing oh my god did you say break
dancing
i was like rolling stone
oh my god so we basically
down and i feel guilty now here's the
thing
i just got on the ground for you man to
break dance i don't have enough space
what am i going to do i better get this
right with my face
we're going to have those glitters for
the rest of time um okay
sorry if okay okay so we need four right
to win a prize for everyone in our house
seats i feel fine i feel confident
i feel confident so maya is giving clues
this time mute her mic
and 60 seconds on the clock so and i can
man
eating eating
spaghetti smell
what sushi eating
you're eating something soup you're but
spaghetti
noodles oh oh oh oh
flipping a pancake flipping a pizza
pizza
a round pizza frying pan
you can say it okay
two words second word
rain no first word
[Music]
purple ryan
fourth fourth one okay
second word i can't see that i can't
pillow stripe
stripe white stripes
pillow it was pillow i said pillow i
said pillow
okay
you know what i'm going to do i'm going
to i'm going to break dance please
she said clarks
girls
[Laughter]
[Music]
it was intense it was amazing brain so
good in fact you couldn't
name it everyone in our house seats is a
winner y'all
in honor of maya's movie luca which is
set on the italian riviera you're all
getting an emerald legacy pasta and
beyond pasta maker
you're welcome enjoy fresh homemade
pasta at home in just
minutes plus it doubles as a juicer and
frozen dessert maker damn
so you can make sorbet frozen yogurt and
even gelato a whole italian meal this
thing makes okay
thank you so much for playing maya i
can't wait to break dance for you in
person one day
i know i'll break dance for you
okay everyone be sure to check out maya
and luca it's on disney plus starting
tomorrow
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever